hello everyone I don't edit my videos
but if I did I would definitely use some
epic dramatic music as an intro to this
game as this is the original immortal
game it was played in 1851 in London
between Adolphe Anderson and Leon okay
said it's ki and Anderson was considered
to be the strongest player in the world
in the period of 1850 to 1866 he didn't
lose that match against Paul Morphy when
Morphy was travelling around Europe but
you know everybody lost a match against
Murphy so after morphe retired soon
after that trip anderson was again
considered to be the strongest player in
the world all the way to 1866 to his
match against William Stein is that
Stein it's one and Anderson won I mean
human a lot of strong tournaments he
wants some of the strongest tournaments
ever held in that era and it's said that
he won more than 50% of the tournaments
that he entered most of his most of his
achievements in chess were actually
after he passed the age of 50 so it's a
bit different than today and this game I
mean well all of his games are
spectacular but this game is something
else as he was the greatest chess
romantic to ever live and he inspired
people in his era and he inspires people
today when they watch his games so let's
see this this is the original immortal
game understand is white and kiss his
black we have E 4 E 5 and we have F 4
banders and the King's gambit we have it
captures on f4 and Bishop to c4 the
bishops gambit and this is of course in
Whiting like to play Queen to h4 check
which he does so we have Queen to h4 and
King to f1 and okay this does lose the
temple plinking to f1 but wife will
recover the temple with Knight f3 and
attacking blacks Queen and here we have
a move that is well in those days it was
played but it's not really a good move
we have b5 and this is to deflect this
bishop from hitting f7 and you know to
get some development and one time they
actually offered Garry Kasparov to play
this position as black against I think
it was against Sheriff
and Kasparov said that I have no plans
in playing this position with black
against zero as this is a terrible move
for black so ok Anderson played Bishop
capture some B 5 and we have Knight to
f6 and now White has a series of moves
that are explicitly targeted at the
blacks Queen here Knight to f3 attacking
the Queen we have Queen to h6 and now d3
and black plays Knight to h5 this is
protecting f4 twice and also preparing a
knight to g3 check because if the pawn
captures night then Queen captures rook
so Anderson guards against this hit
plays Knight to h4 now Knight to g3
check is no longer possible if Knight to
g3 then simply H captors in g3 and now
the night is blocking the Queen from
capturing the rook and also the knight
is protected now so after night to h4 we
have Queen to g5 and we have Knight to
f5 now we have C 6 and here Anderson
starts his initiative he plays g4 we
have Knight to f6 and now Anderson plays
rook to g1 he sacrifices this Bishop on
b5 which isn't really doing anything but
he will get a lot for this for this
Bishop so we have C capture son b5 and
understand plays h4 and as you can see
it's really getting cramped before the
Queen in here we go Queen to g6 and now
h5 attacking the Queen one more time 20
g5 and now Queen to f3 threatening to
trap the Queen with Bishop captures an
f4 so we have night 2 g8
black has to make some room for the
Queen Bishop captures on f4 and the
Queen to f6 and like it's threatening to
capture this b2 1 so we have a night to
c3 again developing and this is move
16 and as you can see white is
completely developed his pawns are all
the way to fifth rank and but there's
only his Queen out ok here's a piece up
but I mean look at this position we have
Bishop to c5 and here Black gets an idea
he will play Bishop c5 get a temple on
the rook and he will
get some development this way but
Anderson isn't really interested in this
as he plays a night to be five now would
a temple on the Queen so black has to
react to this and it's really not that
easy to play the Queen anywhere if the
Queen stops guarding G seventh and ninth
factors and g7 if the Queen steps on
wrong square a wife could even fork the
king and queen so cases could play the
queen capture some b2 grabbing a pawn
attacking the rook on a1 and they're
still guarding g7 and now both the white
rooks are hanging but as this is
Anderson playing it doesn't matter he
plays Bishop to d6 now attacking this
Bishop on c5 so if black captures the
knight cap shouldn't be six but to check
this will be this will be great for
white so of course black plays Bishop
captures and g1 grabbing a rook and here
we have definitely one of the most
romantic moves ever made we have E 5
Anderson offers up another rook and he
plays d5 just to stop the Queen from
guarding on g7 so okay we have Queen
captures and a1 would check and now King
to e2 and well White has no rooks but he
is a threatening Knight to c7 check and
black stops this he plays Knight to a6
and now Anderson finishes the game in
style
he plays Knight captures on g7 would
check as this is the whole point of this
ePHI move so only one square for the
King left King to d8 and now how do you
create the original immortal game can
you spot the move its Queen to f6 with
check the black King has nowhere to go
there was only one move left for black
he has to play Knight captures on f6 and
I understand finishes the game with
Bishop to e7 and this is checkmate
so yeah an amazing game I remember the
first time I saw this game it was
probably some fifty fourteen years ago
maybe and as from the time I saw this
game I always played the Kings gambit I
didn't really understand it much I did
go through a couple of games but
when I play chess in in school or in
parks or wherever I always went f4 and
then Bishop c4 just so I can get that
Queen h4 and King to have one idea so
yeah definitely definitely a beautiful
game and and and the spectacular example
of how chess was played in that era by
one of the greatest players of that era
so yeah this is the original immortal
game I do hope you enjoyed it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you for watching and I will
see you soon